[Music]  yeah yeah I'm a professional yes when I  got the call to do Sonic it was really  exciting good morning my world job  mister dr. Robotnik he is a madman I  can't with that guy you're mine of  course he's a 300 IQ so it took me a  week and a half to prepare Robotnik  wants to control humanity with his  machines Sonic is a power that he needs  to control the world no but thank you  for asking  oh that's not good  I just thought you might like a latte  with steamed Austrian goat milk  of course I want a latte I love the way  you make them I think I'm kind of right  in the site guys with this character  mustache was ridiculous I wish I could  grow it being able to do a movie that  brings a good memory back and connects  with new generations of people it is  really amazing I've been very lucky in  that regard I'm just having so much fun  [Applause]  we've created a monster we won't be able  to control  [Music]